parents I want to have a serious
conversation with you and I want you to
consider by the time this video is done
first watch the whole thing to show it
to your kids and watch it with them and
ask them what do you think about this
content because if you don't High
likelihood some of these things may be
happening to them and they're
uncomfortable talking to you about it so
as a father of four kids I show clips
like this and I talk to my kids about
things like this because I'm a concerned
parent and I think you are as well so
three stories I want to tell you about
and then we'll get into this whole
concept of cyber bully and what
different aspects it looks like when I
watched movie that I think every parent
in the world needs to watch it's called
disconnect it's disturbing Jason bait's
in this movie it's a story about a
husband and wife busy they're doing
their thing and you know their son is in
school he really liked this girl to the
boys in school find out he really likes
this girl they end up creating a fake
Facebook profile it's a 10-year-old
movie so it's like Facebook back then
the Facebook profile they create with
the girl they like they steal the
picture from her put it on this account
they befriend everybody that he
befriends then they text him DM him on
Facebook and they say hey please don't
tell anybody between you and I I really
like you I'm embarrassed don't tell
anyone and they start he's like oh my
God the girl I like is messaging me
that's insane and they go back and forth
and then eventually these two bullies
say hey I really want to see you nude
and I'll send you my picture if you send
me yours these boys take a picture from
whatever other girl online they send it
to him he's like oh my God I just got
her private you know picture that was
sent to me let me send mine he sends his
when he sends his next day he goes to
school guess what he realized
everyone's laughing at him pointing
fingers at him can you imagine how
humiliating that is this kid realizes
these two bullies faked it that girl
never had any interest in him they did
that to mock him troll him almost
destroy him this kid goes home it's the
most disturbing scene of the movie he
goes home goes to his room turns on
heavy metal music decides to hang
himself music is so loud sister walks in
saves him doesn't die turns into an
Escapade the father's like what happened
trying to go after the other kid's
father and it's such a big Feud mustat
movie Disturbing but you have to know it
because it's truth and it's happening
why is it truth that this is happening
an 18-year-old boy committed suicide
because a 17-year old girlfriend was
texting him saying kill yourself goes
back in the car she gets 2 and 1 12
years ends up only doing I think 11
months and 12 days then a story comes
out last week from New Jersey where
these boys took 30 pictures of girls and
they created deep fakes of them in nudes
humiliation by the way as a person
running an insurance company and a
Consulting Fir and a company myself I'm
getting these stories now firsthand from
parents that are completely Disturbed
saying Pat what the hell do I do it's
happening the only reason these types of
things are happening it's because
parents are uncomfortable talking about
these types of issues because you're
already so busy but as a parent I know
this is important to you we must do a
better job talking about it that's why
I'm creating this video and we're going
to break this down on what different
types of cyber buling is going on today
so we can make sure to the best of our
abilities that our kids are
[Music]
protected okay so if you give value out
of this video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel by the way
while we took this break I had to call
my son because I want to share a story
with you and a picture that I have on my
on the cover of my iPad that I think
will tell you a lot about our kids
needing today's content but I'll tell
you that at the end stick around so
let's get right into it these are the
different types of bullying cyber
bullying there is today number one
exclusion this is when somebody
intentionally leaves someone else out of
an online group or message threat
Believe It or Not kids that bothers them
but it happens today number two
harassment occurs when cyber bully send
persistent and hurtful online messages
to a victim these messages can contain
threats hence this girl we're talking
about Michelle Carter texting her
boyfriend to commit suicide that's
insane but guess what the kid ended up
killing himself at 18 years old even
though his girlfriend was only 17 years
old that's harassment cyber stalking
this is when a cyber bully monitors a
victim's online presence closely this
bully can also make false accusations
and threats against the victim and their
loved ones additionally cyber stalking
can extend to the real world becoming
quite serious and dangerous for the
victim and potentially their loved ones
daxing this is when a cyber bully
maliciously shares personal data about
an individual online that wouldn't
normally be publicly known to harass or
intimidate a victim this could include
personal information such as someone's
home school where they attend Social
Security any of that stuff this has
happened to people I know regularly this
is tough next frapping this is when a
cyber bully uses a victim social media
accounts to post inappropriate content
with the victim's name attached to it in
this scenario the victim is tied to
online content that can damage their
reputation trolling this is when cyber
bullies troll a victim by posting
derogatory comments about them online in
the hopes of hurting these individuals
next flaming this is when a bully starts
posting things or insults and profanity
to a victim hoping to get a reaction
back from the individual they're
offending next denigration this is when
a Cyberbully denigrates a victim by
sending posting or publishing false
information online about the individual
denigration usually consists of cruel
rumors and gossip about a victim next
impersonation cyber bully can
impersonate a victim by posting comments
on social media and chat rooms in the
individual's name doing so can cause a
victim to experience backlash from
others based on the bully's online
comments trickery this is when a bully
can befriend a victim to the point where
the targeted individual feels
comfortable sharing secrets and other
sensitive information including pictures
the bully then publicly releases the
information the victim shares to
humiliate shame or otherwise harm them
next fake profiles cyber bullies can set
up fake online profiles on behalf of
victims they can use these profiles to
publish false content the victim's names
without the victim's consent and last
but not least this next one is about the
movie I talked about disconnect is
called catfishing is when a cyber bully
exploits a victim's emotion a cyber
bully attempting to catfish a victim
creates a fake online identity and
pretends to be someone else the bully
can then engage with a victim using this
false identity and build an online
romance over time the victim May trust
the online user and share sensitive
information with the individual then the
cyber bully can share this information
to embarrass the victim and damage their
reputation or expose them so now if
you're watching this you're like no no
didn't happen to me didn't happen to me
okay some of these things there's
nothing you can do about when you start
creating content you get trolled you
can't help it there's fake profiles
there's people that create fake profiles
to get money out of uh crypto the about
3 years ago a guy created a fake website
of me doing Bitcoin calls and I called
him and I acted like I'm interested and
I recorded the whole thing and I put it
online until eventually he had to cancel
it and I asked him I said so let me ask
you a question how much is Mr bed David
involved in Bitcoin oh I can't disr my
client's information but very how big is
his portfolio position and he's talking
to me and is's asking for money from me
realizing he's full of but these
types of things happen some of the
things as par par all we can do is tell
them yeah this could happen to you but
it's okay some of the things we have to
tell them what not to fall for that's a
trap that's a bigger trap some is
unavoidable some is avoidable that we
need to have that conversation with our
kids so now dangers of online bullying
number one online bullying can lead to
emotional distress and mental health
problems online bullying can damage
relationships it can lead to physical
harm and online bullying can damage a
child's reputation especially when
they're younger it's very very important
they're trying to make friends they're
kind of figuring out their own identity
we got to protect that as parents so gab
which is a phone company identified five
specific problems that contribute to
online bulling and here's what they said
on their website problem number one is
screen time excessive screen time can
cause setbacks in children's health and
their social and emotional development
this can hinder their ability to engage
in typical everyday activities that
enable them to learn about the world and
themselves problem number two social
media social media is are most common
place where kids are exposed to mature
content bad language extreme ideas and
damaging interactions kids can even fall
for perpetrators cyber bullies and sex
crimes problem number three explicit
content I don't need to explain to you
what that means it's explicit content
porn pictures all these other things
number four is actual cyber bulling one
in three kid is a victim of cyber buling
50% of teens witness cyber bullion
regularly 50% of teens problem number
five sex crimes watch the statistics one
in five youth received a sexual
solicitation online one in five 20%
that's not a small number guys that
means if you have five kids one of them
got a message that's a lot of kids
getting messages right 82% of online sex
crimes start with social media 82% let
me give you some more shocking stats
about this online bullying that's taking
place so watch this 95% of teens in the
US are online 95% are online girls are
more likely than boys to be both victims
and perpetrators of cyber buling listen
to what it says victim it's being done
to you and perpetrators doing it to
somebody else girls more than boys
statistics 15% teen girls versus 6% boys
it's important to talk to your girls
about it because they do it more than
boys do Instagram is the number one
platform where this takes place and last
but not least you know what's the most
disturbing stat here only one in 10
victims will inform a parent or trusted
adult of their abuse one in 10 not seven
in 10 not five not three one only 10%
are willing to tell somebody about it
meaning they keep it to themselves let's
continue we got to take a little bit of
a deeper dive with stats take a look at
this annual number of incoming
complaints about internet crimes on the
internet have increased from 2000 to 22
watch these numbers here it's in the
Thousand look at 2000 not a lot 2010
skyrockets then if you look at 2020 2021
2022 look out skyrockets why people have
more time on their hands and guess what
happens more opportunities to bully
others look at the next one here
percentage of Internet users in selected
countries who have experienced cyber
crime in 2022 number one is India 69%
68% look what number two is us then
Australia the global average is 39 we're
at 49 then you got New Zealand France UK
Germany Japan this next one to me is the
most interesting one share of children
owning a smartphone in the US in 2015
2019 and 2021 by age if you look at the
bottom the blue is 2015 the black is
2019 and the gray is 2021 look at the
percentage 8 years old it's from 11% 19%
to today it's
31% we went from 11% in 2015 to 31% in
2021 I don't even know what the number
is in 2023 what do you think it is more
than 31% let's go to 11 years old in
2015 the average 11y old maybe 30% of
them had a phone then it went to 32% in
2019 look at 2021 53% by the way if some
parents are like well what's wrong with
them having a phone it's not a phone
it's a small smartphone that's the
problem with Internet if you have a
phone that you can just communicate with
them and that's it there's no social
there's no Instagram there's nothing
else it's a different story continue
let's go to 14 years old it went from
59% to 81% to 91% if you chose to watch
this video with your kids or your
teenagers kids teens you're probably not
going to like me right now cuz your
mommy and daddy are making you watch
this I'm just telling you straight up
right now here's an article from CNBC
what it says you're not going to like it
but brace for impact okay want to raise
happy successful kids wait as long as
possible to give them a phone says a
Yale expert halting smartphone use for
children and young people until their in
the e8th grade comes with Benefits
according to advocacy group wait until
8th including less risk of anxiety and
depression increased quantity and
quality of sleep more time for physical
activity and Outdoors and by the way you
know what status says on the bottom how
many notifications teenagers get on
their phones 200 notifications a day
these are brains that are forming and
trying to pay attention in school while
their phones are going up ding ding ding
so you can hate me all you want if
you're watching this if your mommy and
daddy tell you you can't have a
smartphone till 8 years old I fully
support that message for you not to get
that phone you got plenty of other
things to do on later on you can have a
smartphone do whatever you want to do
when you're 18 years old or above maybe
you get a phone that your parents can
get a hold of you but not a smartphone
you'll thank your mom and dad later it's
the whole concept of hate me now love me
later that's what end up happening long
term but parents this is deeply
concerning I got one more thought I I
thought I was almost done with his
parents one more thing for you to be
thinking about this kids are going to
come home and they're going to say but
Johnny's got a cell phone but Larry's
parents bought him a cell phone and
Jackie said how come your mommy and
daddy make more money don't buy you a
smartphone your parents are cheap who
gives a I don't care you can call
me whatever you want you're not raising
my kids I'm raising my kids and it's my
job as a leader to raise my kids to give
them an opportunity to be different than
everyone else in the marketplace let
everybody else do whatever they're doing
you don't you lead your kids and be okay
with that I want to show you this next
data I don't know if it reveals anything
but just it's a data worth knowing about
US states with a lowest rate of
electronic bullying among students in
the grades 9 through 12 as of 2019
lowest is Georgia then is Florida Nevada
Colorado Texas Rhode Island Hawaii New
Mexico Ohio Arizona one of the things we
got to do as parents is to keep our kids
busy it's worth knowing about this and
the ones with the highest is New
Hamshire Alaska Iowa West Virginia
Michigan Missouri Kentucky Maine Montana
Arkansas our job is to keep them as busy
as possible so a lot of stats said but
now you may be asking P what do I do
about I'm a parent I want to make some
progress how do I know is there any
signs yes recognize the signs that your
teen may be bullied not bullying we'll
do that in a minute as well but that's
being bullied number one withdrawal from
family events and other social
Gatherings they don't want to have
dinner they're going to their room
Christmas they don't want to be around
other people they're constantly voting
birthday parties no I'm good that's a
bad sign that maybe something's going
out you got to talk to them number two
sudden Decline and performance at school
number three refusal to go to school or
uneasiness about attending why not what
what happened is there a reason
reporting feeling ill to avoid going to
school and it's a constant repetitive
Behavior new avoidance of going online
now signs your kid is bullying not being
bullied avoids conversation about their
online activities or social media use
has multiple social media accounts
switches screens on their computer
suddenly when a parent or teacher is
nearby frequently uses their digital
devices becomes overly upset or
irritated if their digital device is
unavailable and last but not least
before I tell you the story with my son
specific tips for parents number one
delay giving them a smartphone as long
as possible and be okay with I'm not
everybody yeah I'll get you maybe a
phone you know some of the brands are
out there you can Google in and find out
I'm not giving you a smartphone anytime
soon two set clear rules and
expectations for your children's
internet use three use parental controls
on your computer and internet router to
block inappropriate websites and to
monitor your children's online activity
talk to your kids about the dangers of
online bulling and what they should do
if they're bullied and last but not
least teach your children how to report
cyber bulling hey T question for you I'm
doing a video I'm about to shoot a video
right now about uh cyber bullying and
the stuff that happens in school I
wanted to share this picture and the
story of what happened that day are you
okay if I tell the
story uh yes I'm okay you're okay with
that yeah I'm okay with you know what
I'm I'm going to talk about how I'm
weird and how you and I have that in
common but we're both comfortable now
with the fact that we're a little bit
different than everybody
else I I'm fine okay all right thanks
buddy all right okay bye so final
thoughts before we wrap up last week I'm
having a conversation with one of my
sons and I said hey so do you ever Miss
Texas cuz I was in Dallas I was up you
know in Texas yeah I do miss Texas I
said why he says because some of the
most important things in my life happen
in Texas such as what he says do you
remember that one day when I had a hard
time understanding why some kids say
you're different you're weird you're
this you're that I said yeah what about
it he says remember when you asked Mommy
to bring me to the house for you and I
have a conversation together I said yeah
by the way till today if you look at my
iPad that picture is on my iPad uh as
you know one of the main pictures here
because this is he and I talking to each
other this is the day and Jennifer took
the picture I didn't even know she took
the picture until later on she showed it
to me here's what I told him I said hey
just so you know my entire life people
thought I was weird in school cuz I was
a dreamer like you I thought about what
if one day we can do XYZ what if one day
we can build this what if one day we can
go here I said we're wired the same
exact way I said unfortunately when
you're a kid if nobody has a
conversation with you you think it's a
problem it takes normally 30 years to
realize it's a big Power and gift that
God's given you and if somebody doesn't
talk to you about it as a man guess what
you're going to think you're weird and
different which is an actual gift but
you won't find that out until you're 20
25 30 years old and we had this moment
together I like man I never thought
about it that way before uh a few months
ago we're in Bermuda I took one of my
kids out cuz he was dealing with
something else and we sat out there and
we had a great conversation together for
30 minutes and we had a breakthrough
here's a challenge sometimes some people
don't have a father figure in their
lives like I don't even have somebody to
talk to about this bring it up to a
coach or somebody else a man that you
respect or a mom parents your
responsibility our responsibilities to
talk to them as much as possible about
these issues because many times just
like you and I were afraid to talk to
our parents about it they are as well we
got to create a safe space that these
types of conversations can be had with
no judgment with nothing else being
there we're having conversations can do
I have your permission to ask you this
the more we're able to use these few
words and have these important
conversations with them will decrease
the Chan of somebody bullying them and
they'll be more aware when it's
happening to them and that's why I think
everybody watching this if you're still
watching this at the end make it a
priority of yours to watch the movie
disconnect with your spouse then if
you're comfortable watch it with your
kids if you got value out of this video
give it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel and if you've not seen the video
I did on the loneliness epidemic click
here to watch the video take care
everybody bye-bye
bye-bye